[Musica]
è molto molto molto molto bello
ritornare su un patto civico per questo
il primo palco che uso da un po di tempo
a questa parte
lo sapete benissimo perché quindi per me
un'emozione oggi doppia e stare davanti
a voi e stare davanti alle telecamere di
questa meravigliosa manifestazione e
oggi parliamo di che cosa ho mai lo
sapete di caos il caos nelle
illusionismo è qualcosa di fondamentale
sembrerà strano perché l'illusionismo è
qualcosa che invece dovrebbe essere
estremamente programmatico dovrebbe
essere ogni gesto ogni istante ogni
momento preparato in anticipo giusto
apparentemente del resto nella vita di
tutti i giorni noi sappiamo benissimo
che il caos è la base fondamentale della
regolarità cioè noi diamo al caos il
titolo di caos semplicemente perché per
noi rappresenta l'inaspettato come i
magi a un trucco è inaspettato ma
l'inaspettato è prodotto semplicemente
dal fatto che noi non conosciamo la
sequenza degli eventi o la sequenza
numerica di andato fattore che ci
porteranno poi a un certo tipo di
risultato non conoscendola noi appunto
ci esponiamo all'inaspettato alla
sorpresa che noi definiamo caos
ora è curioso perché noi siamo degli
esseri estremamente straordinari giusto
siamo eccezionali abbiamo una
costruzione abbiamo dei neuroni abbiamo
delle ossa delle arterie siamo un caos
perfetto e ordinato di organismi che
sono da un certo punto di vista viventi
a sé stanti prendiamo il cervello
cervello diviso in due lobi come tutti
voi sapete il lobo sinistro governa la
parte destra a livello motorio del corpo
e il lobo destro governa la parte
sinistra e già questa è la base di caos
perché non devono governare ognuno la
sua parte simmetrica pensateci nelle
percentuali mondiali il lobo destro che
governa la mano sinistra quindi le
persone mancine è infinitamente più
piccola delle persone che hanno il lobo
sinistro e governa la mano destra che
sono il 70 per cento in più delle
persone mancine quindi anche qui
asimmetria nella perfetta simmetria di
un corpo perché caos nella razionalità
applicato l'illusionismo è facilissimo
guardate usiamo il nostro cervello
destro
usiamo l'emisfero destro vi prego di
farlo perché rimarrete a distanza
sociale senza nessun problema
aprite con me e fatelo perché è molto
curioso la mano sinistra
fatelo per molti di voi essere un po più
difficile perché siamo a specchio perché
questa è la vostra sinistra il vostro
cervello destro ha dato un impulso la
vostra mano sinistra
ora vi chiedo di fare la stessa cosa e
di aprire la mano destra sinistra più
facile che vada la sinistra e altre mani
non le avete ora il vostro cervello sa
di avere due mani nazioni complichiamo
gli il compito girate le mani verso il
basso e vi garantisco che per quanto sia
un movimento semplice il nostro cervello
non lo sta recependo come semplice e
incrociate le mani chiudete le dita
e a questo punto dite al vostro cervello
muove del mignolo sinistro aia qui
cominciano le complicazioni strette così
è il dito sinistro esatto poi provate a
muovere il destro così perfetto ora
avete incrociato i lobi fate quello che
faccio io con le vostre mani però cioè
123 questi questo la signora perso il
polso
questo è il principio del caos nel senso
che abbiamo creato una situazione
inaspettata al vostro stesso cervello
però la sequenza di questi movimenti che
ha portato a questa situazione era
perfettamente studiata
vi faccio un esempio ancora più
pragmatico il girasole voi guardate un
girasole di the bellissimo è una
sequenza estremamente complicata di
piccoli o grandi petali e soprattutto di
tutti gli stami pistelli che trovate al
centro ma attenzione il girasole non è
un caos
segue perfettamente la sequenza di
fibonacci all'interno del girasole ci
sono 34 o 55 seconda che slega in senso
orario o antiorario spirali che formano
il corpo del girasole la sequenza di
fibonacci conosciuta come sequenza o
sezione aurea cioè un perfetto una
perfetta serie di numeri indiscutibili
che vengono applicati dappertutto dalla
musica alla natura del girasole è
l'esempio perfetto addirittura nelle
colonne delle margherite
che hanno 33 o 54 89 petali
straordinario sembra caos perché
sembrano numeri a caso eppure sono
perfettamente identici in sequenza però
sono inaspettati perché non arrivano
come 123
ma arrivano come 33 54 e 89 parte della
sequenza della sezione aurea di di
bonacci facciamo lo stesso esempio con
un mazzo di carte soltanto chiuso e un
mazzo di carte che valga per tutti voi
cioè un mazzo di carte invisibile ok
bene questo è un mazzo di carte
invisibile all'interno ci sono sequenze
di carte dall 1 asso al re 1 2 3 4 5 6 7
8 9 10 jack donna era ripetute per
quattro volte picche cuori quadri fiori
più perfetto di così non c'è caos
apparentemente giusto allora cosa
facciamo
se mescoliamo all'interno del mazzo
immaginiamo che le carte fatelo con me
prendono vita propria ognuno di voi si
immagini che questo mazzo di carte
invisibile che lascio qui abbia carte
mischiate ora non c'è più la sequenza 1
2 3 4 5 ma c'è una sequenza caotica
inaspettata forse 173 forse donna 54
non lo sappiamo inaspettata moltiplicata
per i segni migliaia di possibilità ora
in prima fila
mi rivolgo a voi perché abbiamo una
vicinanza verbale più facile
vorrei che qualcuno esprimesse un
pensiero su una carta cioè la prima
carta che immagina all'interno di questo
mazzo ma è l'unica carta che vede perché
l'unica carta girata tutte le altre sono
di dorso ed è una carta casuale dovuta
al caos
signora lei che mi guarda con così tanto
citando gli antichi con gli occhi belli
mi guardano un favella
mi dica un numero che rappresenta una
carta da gioco o una figura ad alta voce
9 dic
si è abbassata dalla scheda per una
frazione di secondo ma siamo distanti e
le distante quindi va benissimo
9 di picche una carta che lei ha scelto
forse perché le piace come carta ma
forse molte altre persone in questa sala
in questo momento hanno detto 9 di
picche perché ci ho pensato anch'io
qualcuno ha pensato al set di picche
qualcuno ha pensato al sette di cuori
questo perché avviene che ognuno di noi
abbia una risposta al caos quando
veniamo esposti a una sequenza casuale
noi pensiamo di andare a cercare una
carta a caso perché l'ho fatto con un
mazzo invisibile perché se avessi preso
un mazzo di carte in mano dall'inizio
sareste stati in qualche modo forzati
condotti a pensare a quello che volevo
io invece vi ha lasciato completamente
liberi la signora che peraltro mi
perdoni non le ho chiesto come si chiama
e quindi dovrei chiederglielo anche per
cavalleria galanteria come si chiama
sabrina sabrina che non ho avuto invece
di con sé tranne che adesso è anche se
fosse una persona che conosceva non
avere mai detto prima perché sa questa
pagata profondamente ha pensato a questa
carta ora la cosa curiosa la camera
cielo anche qua è che in un mazzo di
carte
le possibilità sono appunto immense e il
fatto di aprire davanti
alla telecamera il mazzo controllarle e
vedere che ecco che qui ad esempio tra
tutte queste carte ce n'è una di dorso
come lei ha visto nel mazzo invisibile e
che questa carta che poteva essere una
fra 52 effettivamente il 9 di picche
è la dimostrazione il rider faceva paura
è la dimostrazione che non c'è caos in
questo tipo di ambiente o meglio il caos
ha aiutato la scelta cioè io in qualche
modo sapevo la carta che lei avrebbe
scelto e lo sapevo dall'inizio tant'è
vero che l'omessa girata all'interno del
mazzo lei voi direte naturalmente questo
sarà un gioco di prestigio sarà un
trucco in realtà non è un trucco è la
sequenza basata sul caos
se il disco velocemente un cubo di rubik
e là delle posizioni casuali e chiaro
questo cubo di rubik in mano che a
milioni di possibilità milioni di
sequenze non tornerà mai a posto
semplicemente muovendo lo con una mano
facendo un passaggio da una parte
all'altra ci sarà un bisogno di uno
sviluppo di qualche genere
ora facciamo un esempio molto chiaro
questo è il cubo di rubik classico
sembra casuale
però ci sono due facce che sono opposte
e contrarie la bianca e la gialla perché
le chiamo opposte e contrarie bianca e
gialla perché vede il punto centrale di
questo caos
ciò che non si ferma ciò che può essere
puntellato allora guardo il punto giallo
e applica un concetto molto semplice
cioè esposto i punti bianchi in modo da
creare una margherita
sul punto giallo questa margherita mi
torna utile perché è un disegno
geometrico quindi non è più caos
ora a questa margherita metto a posto i
petali laterali cioè faccio coincidere i
colori dei petali il blu sul blu il
verde sul verde l'arancione
sull'arancione il rosso sul rosso e
scopro che dall'altra parte adesso del
cubo
non ho più una margherita ma ho una
croce bianca su questa croce bianca che
sembra uscire casualmente io vado a
cercarmi laterali e applico un algoritmo
semplice sempre lo stesso fintanto che i
laterali non si spostano nelle posizioni
che voglio è che pian piano mi vanno a
comporre incredibilmente il cubo sto
applicando lo stesso algoritmo in
continuazione che sarebbe write ap rai
tappa al contrario cioè destra sinistra
destra sinistra destra sinistra destra
sinistra è chiaramente ho fatto una
faccia non solo
ho fatto una faccia ma ho cominciato a
costruire anche i lati delle altre facce
ora potrei dare avanti così per finirlo
ma sarebbe troppo facile perché
pensereste appunto che gli algoritmi
applicati a questo non siano un esempio
di caos
in realtà il caos delle facce e
apparente non esiste esiste un
opportunità che il caos da di stupire le
persone nella velocizzazione delle cose
così come in un libro in un libro ultimo
soggetto di questo piccolo intervento
abbiamo pagine a caso io ne ho preso uno
che non sia un classico che non si sa
nulla un libro forse sconosciuta una
biografia di un uomo che è sicuramente
di interesse non possiamo soffermarci su
questo ma ci soffermiamo sul numero
delle pagine le pagine in questione sono
più o meno 220 221 ora davanti a voi io
mi strappo una la metto qui voi non la
vedete faccio correre il libro davanti
alla camera in modo che la camera lo
possa vedere anche sul laterale tutti
piace questa sono la rete sulla centrale
ok ma nella centrale
questo è importante perché dovete vedere
che le pagine hanno tantissime
informazioni differenziate quindi un
caos di parole e immagini e vi devo
chiedere di scegliere una pagina lo
facciamo sempre con il distanziamento
sociale cioè vi chiedo di fare di dare
uno stop in un certo momento lei che
alla mia sinistra quindi opposto alla
signora mi rivolgo a lei anche perché la
mascherina molto molto bella sembra
hannibal lecter direttamente lei mi dica
stop mentre faccio scorrere le pagine
semplicemente
in questo punto perfetto allora vuole a
questa distanza vedere la pagina
vediamo se non passano abbandoniamo il
numero di pagina ce la fai
vediamo ok è praticamente molto
difficile lo leggo io dovete fidarvi di
me questo caso la pagina 92 ci sono due
immagini
ok chiudiamo la pagina ci teniamo il
libro in vista
ora le pagine corrono in sequenza giusto
quindi correndo in sequenza le pagine vi
danno l'idea di caos di random di
sequenza casuale
eppure è strano perché ci dovrebbe
portare un risultato
la scelta della pagina casuale a
qualcosa che comunque non riteniamo
estremamente interessante dal punto di
vista del calcolo è invece un calcolo
che andrebbe fatto perché mi ritornò
passo di lei qual è il numero della
pagina che abbiamo visto con difficoltà
qual è il numero della pagina come 92 e
cosa ha visto all'interno della pagina
che le è rimasto in me impresso due
immagini e quale quale di queste due
immagini che era più particolare che ha
stimolato di più la sua attenzione sono
uguali e di che colore erano queste
immagini ma di grigi giusto c'era un
numero su un'immagine delle scritte ok
qualcun altro è riuscito a leggere
meglio il numero che c'era sull'immagine
no ok
sapreste riconoscere la pagina però
giusto salary vedeste bene allora questo
punto andiamo a pagine 92
vediamo 11 39 51 67 77 83 85
questa cosa è curiosa
c'è una pagina è stata strappata prima
di questo esperimento è che coincide con
la pagina 92 perché la prima pagina che
si chiama nelle 90 e l'altra 93 e che ci
crediate o no
poi avete visto qualcosa che non è mai
accaduto perché la pagina che ho
strappato prima è la pagina 92
questo dimostra che io sono riuscito a
preordinare non soltanto la vostra
aspettativa visiva ma anche la vostra
aspettativa cognitiva e far rivedere
qualcosa che non esisteva utilizzando
quindi la base del caos anche in questo
caso che quello dei numeri
io vi ringrazio di questa attenzione e
per chiudere citiamo shakespeare dicendo
appunto che sono venuto a seppellire il
caos non per lodarlo a maggior ragione
evviva il caos grazie
[Applauso]